thank you everybody thank you very much
how are you guys
yeah so here's a lot about myself I love
going camping I've gotten so into it
left years
I don't think eyes do or not it's so
much fun only problem with camping they
never tell you the real experience and
the movies and stuff they always like
it's gonna be you all alone in nature
well that'd be gracious you alone in the
woods you know I get that would be great
it's never that it's you in a tent and
you're nine feet away from another tent
on about you guys but that close next to
a single father trying to reconnect with
his son it's not the best place to do
mushrooms right over here makes it very
uncommon sitting outside was camping
right we all let me say Paige there's no
other reason to be out there if you're
not on mushrooms it's just dirty
otherwise don't go there stay inside
with his less dirt but I guess if you're
on mushrooms dirt goes away or something
I don't know
science exactly but I was on him and I
wanted wait for my group for a while
because his deer came he looked at me
weird it was a bad scene you weren't
there and uh I left and as I'm walking
away if Kramer crossed his fork in the
path on two different directions on the
left-hand side it's a really wide path
on the right-hand side it's really
narrow path I couldn't decide which way
to go and while I was deciding all of a
sudden remember thinking of that that
Robert Frost poem from high school you
guys remember that
two roads diverged in a wood and I took
the road less traveled I'm like dude I'm
in a wood right now
and there's two we're doing this frosty
it's been 25 years we're doing it
and so I saw the narrow path the road
let's travel then I went that way and it
turns out it's horrible advice the road
less traveled is full of thorns first of
all it goes inside a creek for like 35
feet for no reason and then it just ends
in the middle of the woods and you get
lost always take the road more traveled
so way better Road that's why more
people travel on it robert frost's of
idiot we should trust most of the people
that came before you
that's how Yelp works are you better
than Yelp honor Falls you know like I
know the restaurant with only one star
cuz I marched the beat of my own drummer
like you march to the bathroom with
diarrhea the five-star place if the
money's the same always go to the 5-star
place over the one-star place unless
it's only got one review then you can't
trust it those are my favorite we're
like always eww it's always like my son
is a good cook
this is biased journalism yeah you gotta
wait for a hundred ratings then you can
trust it
it works away for Yelp and and for porn
videos never get a porn video for five
stars don't mind if I do
and you're like wait one rating no no no
no I'm not trusting that degenerate no
way no way till is a hundred of views at
least some ratings by the way whose
rating porn videos every one of those
videos is like a hundred thousand likes
their dislikes but I don't know who's
doing but like who's finished with that
act and then instead of immediately
leaving the scene in disgust at your
midday decision who's returning to the
scene of the crime like an arsonist
for what why are you like no I care
about my community and I want others to
know that Becky does like it hard
a lot of times you got to register a
profile first do you know how detailed a
process that is that means you gotta
give them an email address to a porn
site I just trust that they're gonna be
cool with it
wait for them to email your verification
code which you have to take and go back
into the system start up a whole profile
anybody yeah absolutely college girls
love it totally
why don't anybody do that here's what I
do it
it's Keenan's cuz it keeps track of all
the videos that you liked it keeps a
record of all that that you can access
so at the end of the year when Chanukah
comes around my gift to myself is I have
a best of week thank you
you